on apprend des trucs c'est une émission
instructive ça a choqué brigitte un nom
je pense que le noir ça doit être
difficile au bois parce qu'on doit pas
le voir dans le noir
ouais c'est bien plus il prend que 70
des butins effacé fanny 7 à choquer mais
en fait pas du tout
via bombe à filtrer services publics non
mais la vie est une dure lutte il faut
montrer ce genre de trucs
alors jean marie tu as dit la vraie
vulgarité n'est pas celle des mots c'est
celle des attitudes expliquez-vous la
chute du préfet minutes et ben ouais je
pense que c'est vrai je suis plus
étaient proches qui disait que l'on peut
être vulgaire en disant bonjour c'est
vrai que mais il m'arrive de d'insulter
des gens au premier rang au théâtre avec
énormément de tendresse et jamais
personne ne se sent agressé toiture
revendique la vulgaire serbe et moi
c'est mon s'est montré que moi il m'a
donné vulgaire je m'occupe alors
qu'elles sont grandes causes il restait
pas grand chose non plus n'ont ils ont
tout pris les autres aillent en cause
tout moi j'aime et je leur ai dit moi à
la réunion des comics jaradi ben je
verrais bien une grande cause et s'il a
les myopathes la faim dans le monde on
m'a dit attends ça c'est des gros
morceau tu nous laisses alors j ai alors
moi il me reste quoi l'écologie je vais
à l'écologie marc jolivet bernard a
l'air moi je me retrouvais derrière
gérard majax et rika zaraï j adorais
c'est pas un truc que je pourrais
défendre tout seul alors ils m'ont dit
bah si y'a un truc qui tirait pas mal à
toi que des geôles vulgaire ouais tec
est occupée des mst
ouais je voulais dire les jo de piste
les lampions et les mycoses oui t'as
qu'à tout prendre
ouais je rentrais chez moi ma faim a dit
tenez bien tiré mon fils est vulgaire
pour un autre homme comme grande cause
les chevaux de piste les morpions les
nst alors session j'ai bossé dessus
quand même hein c'est à dire que j'ai
travaillé j'ai un conseil à donner à
tout le monde moi quand je sens que je
vais avoir un rapport sexuel avec une
jeune fille
j'emmène toujours un demi-citron plus
que moi alors je suis comment ça
fonctionne vous mettez 2 3 gouttes de
citron sur la choupinette ouais et alors
si les lèveraient bouge pas il faut pas
y aller c'est qu'elle est pas frêche lui
elle est morte
ça c'est des coups et attraper une mst
ou du vinaigre et de l'échalote
n'importe quand ça marche aussi ça faut
toujours prendre soin de faire ça donc
tu combine à la fois le vulgaire les et
les grandes causes ni un voilà je crois
qu'en même temps je rends service quand
même aux gens qu est ce que tu avais
ainsi est ce que tu aurais pas préférer
avoir l'écologie parce que l'écologie si
tu veux tu vas voir maintenant le porno
envahi l'écologie oui regarde